nous sommes avec tarek kayes en direct
de vinnytsia donc quelle est la
situation sur place aujourd'hui tarek
comme les jours précédents sets la
situation ici à vénissieux reste assez
calme mais très tendu rien qu'hier les
autorités ont affirmé avoir intercepté
deux missiles de croisière qui était
dans l'espace aérien de la ville mais
qui n'ont pas réussi à atteindre leur
cible donc en visant les reports il ya
quelques jours la russie a voulu
s'attaquer à des infrastructures vitales
comme cela a été le cas aujourd'hui même
haloutz qu'au nord ouest de l'ukraine de
manière générale la ville ici au niveau
des commerces ils sont tous fermés
toutes les boutiques ont fermé leurs
portes et ce depuis le début du conflit
il ne reste que quelques épiceries
capable d'approvisionner en produits de
première nécessité les habitants les
sirènes retentissent à longueur de
journée et comme je le disais il s'agit
donc d'un calme très précaire l'activité
des déplacés se poursuit également et
surtout celles venant des déplacés
venant des régions de l'est puisque
vinnytsia n'est qu'une étape sur le long
trajet que qu'entreprennent tous ceux
qui fuient les régions bombardé toujours
sur le plan humanitaire on a appris que
la ville s'apprête également à apporter
de l'aide à toutes ces villes qui
souffre actuellement à celles qui sont
assiégés ou en passe de l'être des
villes comme mario paul active kiev
soumis ou au dessin avec cai vous vous
parliez de vinnytsia qui est sur la
route de l'exil de l'exode est-ce que de
l'exode pardon est ce que vous vous
pouvez constater des élans de solidarité
peut être entre les différentes villes
ukrainiennes
tout à fait une grande solidarité qui se
manifeste d'abord par l'accueil de ces
déplacés qui se fait ici comme dans
d'autres vies le venitia compte plus de
35 mille déplacés et ce nombre tend à
s'accroître une autre solidarité qui se
manifeste également pas l'envoi comme je
disais de cette aide humanitaire à
destination des villes qui souffrent et
également par le biais de ses appels
téléphoniques nous avions rencontré hier
le maire de vinnytsia qui a dit être en
contact continu avec les maires des
villes qui souffrent le plus il nous a
parlé par exemple de la ville de
maillots paul il a eu le maire de cette
ville qui lui a fait part des grandes
souffrances et de la grande détresse et
de cette situation humanitaire très
difficile il nous a même dit que la
ville est détruite complètement c'est en
tout cas ce que lui a rapporté le maire
de marioupol mais cette ville de
vénissieux se tourner sur aussi à sa
propre destinée elle se voit aussi dans
la ligne de mire de l'armée russe ce
qu'on craint ici surtout ces deux fronts
principalement le front nord si kiev
tombe ça sera le taux à 2 g thomert et
si j'ai thomert est encerclé ça sera
tout de suite après venitia c'est ce que
nous attend a affirmé donc le maire et
on craint également le front sud puisque
on n'est pas très loin de la frontière
moldave et en particulier de la
transnistrie où se trouve en grand
nombre des soldats russes merci beaucoup
tara cahier bercy à votre compagnon de
route luxe ragots un pur pour les pour
les images merci à vous